it's the story of a mother's love for
her son and desperate attempts to get
him back in October last year while
Tatiana was out Russians sees 17 year
old Vlad and took him away
my child left without my knowledge or
permission when I found out he was
already there I was very angry
Vlad was put in body armor by armed
Russian men in balaclavas and taken
against his will to be held in camps in
occupied territory for the next eight
months
I missed him and worried about him
especially when there was no
communication when the connection was
cut off
oh
I was really concerned I missed my boy a
lot
vlad's new life was one of
indoctrination by the Russians in photos
he sent his mother he was beginning to
change taught how to use guns how to box
here in red in the ring and there were
more worrying signs Vlad sent her
pictures of himself with injuries a
broken leg and finger
there was mental and physical abuse he
says and when he tried to leave he was
punished
I felt bad because I didn't like the
camp I was interrogated and asked why I
left I said I wanted to go home to
Ukraine okay you know the monkey but
the Russians put Vlad into solitary
confinement he says where he considered
killing himself
it was difficult five days not talking
to anyone and all you see is just
someone bringing you food and you are
sitting and thinking what to do you're
just isolated you don't hear anything
it's like you are deaf I was thinking
about suicide
back home Tatiana asked a charity for
help a handful of mothers plotted to
bring back their children
to rescue Vlad Tatiana would risk a
perilous Journey leaving her son and
driving to Poland and onto Belarus then
flying to Moscow an Overland through
Russia by train to krasnadar and across
Crimea to Luzerne in occupied Ukraine
where she was reunited with her son
describe the moment when you saw him
again in the camp slow them
slowly tears tears I was crying I just
hugged him and cried
I didn't have any other emotions just
tears running out of my eyes
but her ordeal wasn't over the Russians
held tetiana for six days and
interrogated her for 10 hours at times
sticking a bag over her head it must be
it must have been terrifying for you
every time I think about it I just want
to forget it like a nightmare that never
happened
I had lots of different thoughts I
worried that they could have taken me
and I would never have returned I feared
I'd never see any of my children again
not just vlades
in the end the Russians let Vlad go with
Tatiana he's back in Ukraine with his
family but his mother's worries haven't
ended vlad's eight months in Russian
camps have changed him she says and he
can't open up about what really happened
there
it pains me deeply that I've come all
this way and he just pushes me away I
feel offended I can't understand him and
as a mother I forgive him because I
don't know the whole truth about what
happened to him maybe he's doing this
because he just wants to protect me
law were telling that all children the
charity that helped Tatiana bring Vlad
back says the others left behind in
Russian camps are being turned into
young Russians to help their war on
Ukraine
I think the worst that these children
will
be growing
with the hate of Ukraine they will
will grow and will receive Russian
citizenship and will go fight against
Ukraine to understand that Ukraine is is
the evil is the enemy
and
I I'm very afraid that well lost
thousands or hundreds of thousands
children
who Russia brainwashed Russia says it's
doing all this to rescue children from a
war zone
about 300 children were placed in
families and it wasn't an adoption but a
temporary provisional guardianship or
temporary trusteeship and such a form
was chosen specifically taking into
account the fact that parents can appear
and of course these parents will have
every opportunity to take their children
away if they're interested
but Vladimir Putin and his children's
commissioner have been charged with the
war crime of deporting children by the
international criminal court and today
Ukrainian prosecutors accused a Russian
and two Ukrainian collaborators of
taking 48 young children some as young
as one from this Children's Home in
Harrison
vlads may be back on Ukrainian soil but
the trauma inflicted by the Russians is
still with him and his mother and a
cross-occupied Ukraine and deep into
Russia so many more like him have yet to
come home and perhaps never will